brands are doing way too much every time
I look at my phone Starbucks wants to be
my bestie Netflix wants to chill even
Skittles wants to know if they're um cap
or No Cap why is it all so cringe Brands
using slang is nothing new from the
brand saying Bay 2010s to the what's up
as of the 90s advertisers are always
trying to find ways to sound cool but
when brands on social media use a slang
word in their marketing that basically
guarantees it's over we understand that
Brands didn't come up with these words
and they're not part of the groups we
think should be using them but why what
makes a word slang and why does it sound
so weird when some people or companies
use it I'm Dr Erica brazovsky and this
is other words
[Music]
foreign
slang isn't so much a type of word as a
type of communication it's the specific
words we choose the type of delivery we
use and even the context we use them in
all the stuff that sociolinguists call a
register while there's no set definition
for slaying we know it doesn't serve a
syntactical function it's more of a
social one we also can't agree on which
words are or aren't slang words like
bread and bomb feel like slang whereas
words like cash are cool that started
out as slang now feel like everyday
standard language rather than a rigid
box slang is more of a fluid category
that words move in and out of all the
time so how do we know what slang is
when we hear it well there are a few
characteristics that we can use to
quantify how slangy a word is Let's Take
a Look
slang usually arises from a small group
or subculture remember on fleek the sly
term for being perfect precise or
looking really good it was coined by
peaches Monroe a young black woman in
2014. ibraham's on fleek the word caught
on with black Vine and Twitter users and
eventually spread all the way to Denny's
Twitter feed
but that's a pretty common pattern we
got slang like yes and slay from the
queer and trans ballroom scene I don't
have to tell you because you know you're
and that's shade
young people Gamers and the extremely
online all have their own in-group slang
these subcultures often marginalize or
outside of the mainstream develop their
own vocabularies slang is a shorthand to
tell other users I'm part of your
community I share your values or I just
get you of course as slang moves from
small communities say students at your
school to students on social media to
everyone on social media to your parents
those words become less associated with
a group identity and therefore less
slangy this is one of the big reasons
Brands using slang throws us off Brands
want to show that they're in with the
cool crowd when they call their
potential customers bestie or Bae but
smart consumers and language users can
tell when it's not authentic Brands
appeal to Broad audiences not Niche
underground subcultures so the slang
they use becomes kind of basic
[Music]
speaking of on fleek slang words also
tend to have short life spans my
Millennial slang Probably sounds ancient
to a genzir and neither of us would call
something Nifty or swell or the bee's
knees
while some slang survives the test of
time think Awesome from the 80s or the
1920s gig for a short-term job usually
the newer a word is the more slangy it
feels but remember slang starts in
subcultures and in groups and it takes a
while to spread to larger and larger
speech communities by the time new words
make it to whoever runs those brand
social media accounts they're not quite
so new anymore that's how you end up
with Brands using new 2023 slang that
you already stopped using in 2020.
slang is usually a synonym for General
and frequently used words how many slang
words can you think of that mean good or
bad or even interesting or annoying
there's also a ton of slang for alcohol
drugs sex and other taboo topics that
speakers use when they want to be a
little more discreet but usually when
someone uses groovy instead of good or
wasted instead of drunk they know the
more widely used synonyms but they
choose to use the slang term instead to
convey their understanding of the
audience they're speaking to and the
context they're speaking in you might
talk about your partner at work but your
BF or GF in the group chat romantic
partner is another General category with
lots of slang synonyms Boo Honey wifey
Bae but bread Bay that's not a thing
when a brand takes a word that's meant
to be General like a partner and tries
to make it specific like the kind of
bread you favor at a sandwich restaurant
that's not slangy using slang isn't just
about proving you've heard the word it's
also about showing you understand the
context for it
lastly slang is usually used in informal
settings you may use it when talking to
friends or family but not when giving a
presentation at work or in an essay for
class in fact slang lexicographer
Jonathan Green notes that until the rise
of social media enabled us to have
informal conversations Online Slang was
primarily a spoken language most of it
never got written down at all even
though Brands may want to sound casual
when they use slang online a corporate
account that someone runs as their
full-time job is never going to be
informal right so brands are constantly
taking slang from an informal context
into a formal one even a PBS show is
kind of a formal context so any words I
use in this episode have become a little
less slangy just because I'm using them
my bad all these characteristics help us
pinpoint how slangy a word is at a
moment in time but it will never stay at
that point for long slang is a gradient
by using a slang in different contexts
we can move it along the gradient from
slanging to not slangy in Mother Nature
Brands just happen to be really good at
moving words in the non-slanging
direction but even more important than
what counts as slang is how we use it
remember when I said that slang is a
register of communication that serves a
social function that's because every day
we use slang to solidify our individual
identities as say a young person or a
woman or a midwesterner as well as our
membership in groups like tick tockers
or drag queens or sneakerheads Brands
who are trying to Market to those
identities will try to pick up that
slang to sound like they are part of a
social group Mountain Dew wants to sound
like a gamer glossier is a fashionable
it girl slang use provides us with a
sense of community belonging and even
safety think about slang words like woke
which black people started using to
communicate awareness of systemic racism
or friend of Dorothy a phrase queer
people use to identify each other when
it was otherwise unsafe to come out
Outsiders often originate slang to to
identify who is trustworthy or
comfortable to be around and even now
social media subcultures are regularly
inventing New Slang to get around
algorithmic censorship and content
filters so if a faceless corporate
account that doesn't need these words to
build relationships or communicate
safely use them just for the clout
that feels inauthentic AF lucky for all
of us though language is constantly
evolving by the time Brands disrupt the
social function of slang words slang
users are already well on their way to
creating new ones which we'll probably
see in a skittles ad in about five years
the 1920s gig for a short small
ethics and Technical function
Denny's Twitter feed
[Music]